alors ça y est tu les as oui j attends
on les superpose pas et on se fait pas
mal enlève tes doigts ok c'est bon des
décors angoissants s'installent dans
cette paisible maison à quelques jours
de la première les équipes de la
compagnie pixom paufinent les derniers
détails de ce cabinet de curiosité des
vendredi 27 octobre sera lancé le
nouveau spectacle d'Halloween la maison
hantée Once Upon punk un univers
postapocalyptique futuriste proche de
celui du film Mad Max avec une
esthétique végétale et donc résiste un
petit groupe de nécromanciens qui
eux-mêmes perdent des membres dans leur
dans leur petit groupe et trois d'entre
eux partent en quête d'un élément qui va
pouvoir de nouveau redorer la flamme un
petit peu de de l'imagination faire
renaître la création dans la tête des
des des êtres humains de toute créature
vivante et il tombe sur cette bâtisse 12
acteurs donne vie à des personnages haut
en couleur astremec Amelia Hart ou
Atropos une représentation im ive et
participative où le visiteur déambule à
travers différents espaces chaque
comédien suit un caneva narratif avec
une grande place laissée à
l'improvisation on est dans cette cette
euphorie cette envie ce plaisir cette
joie de de participer quand même à un
spectacle c'est très excitant
infernal dans le bon sens du terme un un
délirant parce que voilà les les décors
sont phénoménaux tout le monde met la
main à la patte et ça c'est super je
vais placer ça sur le le plafond et avec
les petites alvéoles que je vais venir
bomber avec une bombe
dorée ça donnera une impression
d'alvéolle de ruche et de miel qui coule
quatre techniciens 15 décorateurs et une
centaine de bénévoles un travail de
fourmis pour installer des dizaines de
milliers d'éléments récupérés et
revisiter d'un spectacle à l'autre une
démarche écoresponsable propre à l'ADN
de la compagnie on a un partenariat avec
la Ressourcerie du pereline et grâce à
eux on va sourcer des matériaux qui a
priori partirai plutôt pour la belle et
donc on les récupère on les retaple on
les valorise on en fait des objets de
décor on en fait des objets un peu
magiques qui ensuite pourront
éventuellement repartir dans le réseau
ou continuer à avoir une vie en tant que
décor rendez-vous au mycélium de la
commune des brevvières jusqu'au 4
novembre pour découvrir cette maison
mystérieuse perceuse marteau et
sissotteuse les équipe de pixom
travaille d'arrache-pied pour vous faire
vivre cette expérience nocturne et
horrifique